One of the reasons quantum mechanics is hard
to get your head around
is because it’s just so friggin' weird.
Things at the quantum level behave completely
counterintuitively,
compared to what we’re used to
out here on the macro-scale.
Recently, though, scientists have announced
possibly the largest objects yet observed
being governed by quantum physics.
Macroscale objects doing quantum things
sounds absurd;
at least, Erwin Schrödinger thought so.
That’s what Schrödinger’s cat is all about.
The famous thought experiment says that if
a cat is in a box with an atom
that has a 50-50 chance of decaying and setting off a
Rube Goldberg murder machine,
then, according to one interpretation
of quantum physics,
the cat should simultaneously exist
as both alive and dead.
Erwin Schrödinger dreamed up this scenario
to point out just how ridiculous the interpretation was,
since a cat obviously can’t be both
alive and dead at the same time.
But since then, experiments have shown particles
like electrons and photons
existing in multiple states simultaneously,
demonstrating the quantum weirdness is real.
Still no half-dead cats, though.
But just like how there’s nothing in the
rulebook that says a giraffe can’t play football,
there’s nothing in quantum physics
that says there’s a size limit.
There are, however, two important conditions.
The first is isolation.
An isolated object can behave
as quantum mechanics allows.
But if an object isn’t isolated, the rest
of the world interferes.
Things like other matter and radiation prevent
the object from doing everything possible,
and instead restrict it to what we classically see.
But nothing can be perfectly isolated from
its environment,
so the second condition is energy.
To exhibit quantum behavior, an object must
have more energy than its environment.
These two constraints are why light in a vacuum
is a great candidate for observing quantum behavior.
Scale things up, though, and those two requirements
get harder to meet.
But they can be met, and in April of 2018,
Nature published a paper detailing the largest
objects yet to exhibit the quantum phenomenon
known as entanglement.
Entangled objects are somehow connected over
a distance, and what happens to one
has an immediate effect on the other, what Einstein
dubbed, “spooky action at a distance.”
Using a carefully applied superconducting
electrical circuit, two vibrating circular
membranes were made to oscillate so similarly
they could be considered in an entangled state.
Although these drum-like membranes are just
about the width of a human hair, they contain
trillions of atoms, making them the largest
objects entangled yet.
Compare that to 2015, when the record was
a mere 3,000 entangled atoms.
Macro-scale objects like these could be used
for super-sensitive measurements,
and could be applied to things
like detecting gravitational waves.
So what’s next?
Can I one day entangle my cat with my dog?
Would it be possible to entangle myself with
Beyoncé so I can finally dance like her?
Will we finally get entangled ice skates and hockey pucks like the 1999 Disney Channel original movie
"Genius," that is the basis
for most of my life?
Probably not for a long time, and before that,
a lot more spooky research is needed.
Hungry for more quantum mechanics videos?
Well, you are in the right place.
Click here to watch Trace explain how scientists
successfully achieved Earth-to-space
quantum teleportation... and exactly what that means.
Don't forget to subscribe for more awesome
and crazy science videos every week
and thanks for watching.